I did want to mention at this point that
there are a few other viewport controls
there's an initial scale property that
lets you set what the browser's initial
scaling factor will be this defaults to
1 and usually you don't really want to
mess with it
if you change it to another number it
just changes the initial zoom factor and
the user will probably have to pan or
zoom there is one very critical use to
initial scale though on iOS if you only
set width to device width and you don't
set the initial scale like in this page
when you rotate the screen the iOS web
engine will keep the same viewport width
and rescale it to fit across this
landscape screen it's just stretching
the portrait layout to fit across the
landscape with even though I've set
width the device with iOS is still
scaling the landscape width in fact the
interesting bit is that even if you load
this page initially in landscape mode it
still thinks it's the portrait width
it's just rescaling it to fit in the
landscape screen now if you have the
same page but you set the initial scale
to 1 in the viewport meta element along
with setting device width it'll change
the viewport size when you rotate
instead of rescaling you can see now the
window size is 480 pixels across
it's the landscape width not the
portrait width so in short this is what
you really need to use as your default
boilerplate viewport and meta element
you need the initial scale so that iOS
when flipping from portrait to landscape
mode will still scale correctly an
interesting side note I discovered is
that on iPhones although they're
changing the viewport size properly if
an initial scale is set they're also
changing the default font size for the
document an orientation change
effectively zooming up the text when you
go to landscape mode this means you
should probably set a default font size
on the page not just use m's or
percentages you may want to use a reset
style sheet to do this if you aren't
already